well no Charlie I didn't even ask him we
don't need Potter over here and I'll
take mine now no but you're you're
you're thinking of this place all wrong
is if I had the money back on a safe the
money's not here well your money's in
Joe's house that's right next to yours
and in the kennedy house on mrs. michael
ins house and a hundred others if you
were to counterfeit some US dollars at
home right now you could be punished for
up to 20 years in prison with a fine up
to $250,000 yet in the world of finance
banks are not only able to print money
but they're actually encouraged by the
government to do so banking is one of
the least understood businesses
throughout history and yet they are the
very places that people dump their life
savings into we can just put that into
your retirement account and make it go
to work for you and it's gone what and
the more you look into it the more
absurd you realize it really is so how
does the business of baking really work
it's actually not as complicated as you
may think
[Music]
what's the purpose of a bank in the
first place
for most of us it's the half a safe
convenient place to store our money so
we don't have to carry around cash but
bankers don't open up a bank out of the
kindness of their hearts just to make
our lives easier no at the end of the
day the purpose of a bank is the same as
any LA business to make the owners money
and a name of the game in banking is
collecting interest whether that be from
credit cards mortgages loans to other
businesses and more loans that they have
in the higher the interest rate the more
money banks make but loans aren't
anything special in the fact that they
want to make money doesn't necessarily
make them bad either
after all our modern lives today when it
exists at all if it wasn't for love
value that business has provided but
unlike any other business model out
there banks or the only ones that are
legally able to print money out of thin
air
[Music]
in ancient times the dreams of Alchemist
was to find a way to turn lead into gold
whoever would discover that formula
would basically control all of the
world's money by just creating more gold
today it's a little bit different
because the world doesn't base its money
on gold anymore
in fact money isn't really based on
anything anymore it's what's called fiat
money money that's really nothing more
than paper that the government says it's
money and we use this paper money
because we believe in the government and
the economy enough not tomorrow we can
exchange our money for something like
the new call of duty modern warfare game
that I've been playing way too much of
recently and it's in this fiat money
system that bankers have become the
modern-day Alchemist with the ability to
literally create money out of nothing
and when you get past all the technical
jargon the process is actually not all
that complicated and the magic happens
every time you deposit money into your
bank account here's how it works let's
say you get a paycheck for $10,000 and
you deposit it into your bank account
now even though the only reason you
deposit your money in a bank in the
first place is because you expect to
take out that money to use later banks
are required by law to only keep around
10% of that $10,000 you deposited as
reserves that means out of the $10,000
you deposit in the bank has the power to
take $9,000 of your money and lend it
out to other people as loans and if you
understand that short little scenario
you understand how banks print money in
a nutshell
wait really that's it still low confuse
let's rewind let's pretend only you the
bank and the person the bank let your
money to Frank exist in this imaginary
world you start out with your $10,000
the bank and Frank have $0 so a total
amount of money in circulation or the
money supply is only $10,000 you deposit
your money into the bank because you
don't want to be walking around with
$10,000 in cash and you don't think
stuffing it and your mattress is a very
good idea you're not giving the bank
your money you're just laying them hang
on twits la you have some convenience
and peace of mind that you can use that
money later whenever you want but since
banks or businesses are here to make
money
and that they only have to keep only 10%
of the money they get in reserves why
would they just let your money sit there
when it could be out collecting interest
for them and making them money and so
this Bank says look we are in a world
where our reserve requirement is 10%
which says that the bank only has to
keep 10% of these cash reserves and then
it can loan out the rest and so it does
that that's its business model or a
significant part of its business model
so they lend out 90% of your money or
$9,000 as a loan to Frank at a 5%
interest rate so that Frank could start
his door-to-door kitchen knife sales
business feast your eyes on your new
business
all of a sudden and Frank has $9,000
suspend you still have your $10,000 as
digits on your online bank statement
that you can still take out and spend
and what started out as $10,000 in the
money supply has magically increased to
$19,000
and the bank they get to collect 5% in
interest or $450 every year for the
$9,000 they created for Frank from the
money they got from you let me repeat
that the bank makes money by lending out
money that they created out of thin air
from your money I don't know about you
but maybe I should just quit YouTube and
start a bank but before you do anything
rash there's more it gets even better
because Frank is also like you he
doesn't want to keep his money in his
mattress so what does he do before
spending it the nine thousand dollar
loan he got goes directly into his bank
account and guess what since the bank is
there to make money and they only have
to keep 10% of Frank's money in reserves
now they can take 90 percent of Frank's
nine thousand dollar deposit which was
based on your deposit and take that
eight thousand one hundred dollars and
lend that out to other people I collect
interest on that money
and when that second loan is created
from Frank's deposit the money supply
jumps from nineteen thousand dollars
after the first loan to 27 thousand one
hundred dollars with that second loan
and who has the pleasure of collecting
all the sweet interest on all of these
loans the bank's extrapolate this very
oversimplified process out to the entire
country in the world and you have the
modern banking system of fractional
reserve banking where banks are only
required to keep a certain fraction of
the deposits that they get in reserves
and they can lend out the rest to make
money and since the people who deposited
their money into the bank have a right
to use that money and take it out
whenever they want even though the bank
lent out their money to other people the
money that they lent out is basically
money that they created out of nothing
that they get to collect interest on
[Music]
and that is what makes banking so
powerful in no other industry do people
enthusiastically hand over their life
savings to you that you can legally
create more money and then collect
interest on the money you just created
and to see what this looks like in real
life the biggest public bank in the u.s.
right now is JPMorgan Chase and in 2018
alone they collected seventy seven point
four four billion dollars in just
interest alone now some of you may be
wondering but if banks only have to keep
ten percent of the money they get from
customers what if the customers want to
withdraw more than ten percent of their
deposits what happens then this has
actually been a problem throughout the
history of baking with what are known as
bank runs bank runs are almost
inevitable with fractional reserve
banking and because at the end of the
day people are gonna eventually want
their money back
so to mitigate this the government put
together the FDIC to guarantee people
that if the bank can't give their
deposits back to them they'll be insured
for up to $250,000 for each person at
each Bank on the surface that sounds
really good as a customer of the bank
schürrle Bank is making money with your
money but least your money is guaranteed
by the government but it also poses
another huge benefit to the business of
banking from their perspective if
depositors are always guaranteed by the
government to get their money back where
is the incentive for banks to act
ethically with their customers money
what's stopping them for being asked
risky as possible so that they can make
as much money as possible when worst
case scenario they'll be bailed out by
the government
so how absurd is the business of banking
well when you consider that we willingly
hand them all of our money they create
more money out of nothing they lend out
that made-up money to collect interest
to make more money for themselves and
it's guaranteed by the government it's
it's pretty absurd our entire working
lives are centered in one way shape or
form around us making money so isn't it
interesting that you had to learn about
this thing called fractional reserve
banking that pretty much runs the entire
world from a free YouTube video isn't it
interesting that this thing that is part
of the backbone and foundation of how
the world economy works isn't part of
the public school curriculum it actually
wasn't always like this
back during the early presidential
elections of the US banking was a big
issue that was understood by the public
and can be compared to modern-day issues
were familiar with today like war and
climate change but somehow that faded
with the passing of time I think
especially if you want to make money it
becomes even more important to
understand how money works where it
comes from and what people are doing
with their money and really guys we've
barely scratched the surface of the
monetary world in this video and this is
a topic that I'm really going deep into
right now so if you want to learn more
let me know in the comments down below
I'll definitely make some more videos
for you guys
[Music]
you you're partly watch the end Club but
in all seriousness guys thank you so
much for watching to the very end and we
actually have a does in a while so go
ahead and leave in the comments down
below if you're watching this right now
hashtag I watched in the very end it's a
really simple thing that you guys can do
to help out the YouTube algorithm to
give it a nice little boost and if you
enjoy the style of video for the
entrepreneur niche please consider
subscribing and turning on that
notification bells that you to notify
see whenever I release a new video what
else uh you can follow me on instagram
at jake trend I oh and yeah that's gonna
wrap it up you've been awesome
I've been Jake I'll see you guys in the
next one
[Music]